make an impact hello everyone welcome
from New Orleans I'm here with sage
speaking at their small business summit
it's I think the largest event for
entrepreneurs in the world or there's
about eight thousand people here and
this is usually my book update time slot
and I haven't had time to work on my
book this week at all the main reason is
because my big goal for doing everything
that I do is to have a big impact that's
what I'm here on this earth to do that's
my mission I want to help entrepreneurs
in a big way and so when this
opportunity came up I had to take it
knowing that I wouldn't be able to spend
this week right in my book because it's
important it's more aligned with my
mission than spending the week at home
write in the book and so today as an
example today is false me writing day
today was supposed to be writing day
instead I delivered a session at the
event I did two interviews I handed out
an award I just got back it's it's
quarter past ten handed on the ward and
left I'm trying to find my wife on
facebook to have a quick chat with her I
am obsessed with these smoothies these
are ginormous the smoothie king stuff is
huge this is like kale and the mix of
stuff and so sometimes it's okay not to
sometimes it's okay to deviate from your
schedule if it's the opportunities come
up that are more tune with your goals
and so that's what I'm about having an
impact I got a lot of questions this
time last week no questions one from
mark Draeger about mosquitoes and this
week tons of questions so i am going to
go through the rapid fire and see how i
can get through them i'm sitting here in
the hotel room in New Orleans okay first
up dread dog thanks to the video how do
you stay motivated I've done lots of
videos on this I think the easiest way
is Christine if we can link that up a
couple the videos about staying
motivated that's probably easiest bet
than spending seven minutes going
through it here but I love the question
and it's one of the most important
issues facing a lot of entrepreneurs J
reyez question for next week is the
books content name topic publishing a
chapter titles etc short in the mystery
on purpose if so why you know curiosity
is part of my brand and I like keeping
things a secret to some extent
in advance of promoting things i don't
know i just i like i like surprises i
like surprising people this one uh I'm
walking a line even with these videos um
you know I'm not supposed to say too
much about what I'm doing in advance of
it coming out um so I don't know if I'm
allowed to say the title and some of the
topics but I want to keep an open
dialogue with you guys and so I really
probably should have a discussion with
my publisher and talk about what I'm
allowed to say what I'm not allowed to
say yeah so is a short and mr. on
purpose partially but most of it is
thinking that I don't want to get in
trouble with my publisher I mean I've
gotten trouble people before but I want
to keep that relationship next Shane
buys when is your book coming out and
will it also be an e-book format the
schedule ah time for me to complete the
manuscript is this october i believe
it's october 15 so i got some writing to
do and the release date would be next
fall or end of summer probably august
some somewhere and so it's a bit of a
it's a bit of a wait that's that's kind
of the game unfortunately ebook format
I'm thinking yes that wasn't um I don't
that was discussed if it wasn't pretty
much attention to it probably i would
say probably next since I Ryan did did I
go to VidCon didn't see you there no I
did not go to VidCon um I don't know if
I've become a snob or what but I don't
really go to events much anymore one I
find that the topics you know I like the
go all in on stuff you know when I
commit to something I'm all-in and I
know a lot about very narrow topics and
very little about what else is going on
in the world there's so much stuff in
pop culture and politics and all the
stuff that I have no idea what's
happening and I'm okay with that because
when I go in on something I go all in
and so what I find is going to events
going to conferences if I'm interested
in it I probably would have learned the
information anyway that maybe let me
sound like super snobby but i'm already
watching videos i'm already reading the
blogs my already falling to people that
i need to follow on twitter and engage
in and soaking up the knowledge and so
if i'm going to a conference I find that
I learned very little and the stuff that
I am learning i'm not interested in so i
don't go to conferences anymore
the other thing is one of the big
benefits of going to events is the
networking meeting people exchanging
ideas making contacts and as I talked
about before I I suck at that I don't
enjoy it I'm not a networker and so I
try to put myself in positions where I
can deal from what I'm good at instead
of weakness what I don't enjoy when I'm
not good at and what I don't want to
improve at to be honest so I go to
conferences when I'm speaking I go to
conference when I'm paid to speak and I
feel like it's going to have an impact
and I'm gonna be able to reach some
entrepreneurs so I was not asked to
speak at VidCon and so I did not go to
VidCon nothing against VidCon and I'm
glad you had fun sensei Ryan and maybe
you can make a video about what you
learned at VidCon see if I missed out
and if you did who knows next ciao cacao
2000 that's an awesome name ciao cacao
2000 how do you determine when you share
your great idea with others especially
service based business ideas or others
particular when you're networking as
opposed to just sharing a gene with
close family so what kind of strain from
the book idea a little bit here but
quick answer for you is there's so much
that you have to worry about in the
execution that the idea doesn't mean
that much to be honest like if you're
talking to somebody at a networking
event and you share a high level version
of what you want to do with your idea
that's not giving it away you want to
talk about the problem and talk about
the solution the way that nobody can go
out and just do it from that spark right
if they could do it then probably tons
of people have that idea and and you're
going to lose because you're not
executing well and I'd rather be out
sharing the idea and building my team
and talking to people who are passionate
about it and might be able to help me or
connect me then just telling my family
about it and losing because I don't
build the team to help me execute so I'd
be up sharing it Joshua Joshua wrote a
long question I don't know my passion
and I'm focused on climbing the
corporate ladder but a friend of mine
suddenly introduced network marketing
promises good returns any advice and so
confused what to do setting down my
goals don't know where to go what I want
to be Thanks okay don't go into network
marketing that's not the answer man
first of all you never want to go into a
business because you're trying to make a
lot of money that is the fastest path to
failure because if you're not sticking
to it you're not committed
you're not in passion you're not in love
with it you're not going to have results
of anything right you get into anything
without passion you try to be a husband
without pass you try to be a father
without passion you try to be a friend
without passion try to be an
entrepreneur without passion whatever it
is if you don't have passion you will
not succeed you won't get results and
you won't be a happy person either don't
chase network marketing that one can
work it works for a lot of people but
don't chase it just because you're
looking at returns that's that's the
path to failure one hundred percent if
you don't know what your passion is I
would say it's time to explore you got
to explore you gotta look at different
options you got to say yes to things try
them out you could you could try the
network marketing if you feel like there
might be some kind of spark or interest
but not if you're just trying to make
money and try a bunch of other stuff too
and see what sticks and see what you
love and see what you feel like you can
really sink yourself into and make
returns be your secondary objective
right first is fall in love with what
you're doing if you do that you
providing value to people you'll make
more returns and you thought were
possible next up Matt asked question
what way of storytelling is the most
engaging that would make an immense
emotion that would in turn create
emotion Thanks this is a interesting
question I touched on storytelling last
week in the video and is an awesome way
to convince people there's a lot of
different ways you could do it and I'm
not sure that I am the expert on
storytelling the two that I find super
helpful one are when you're telling a
personal story a personal example and
the others when you're telling somebody
else's story so I could tell the story
about Sylvester Stallone and rocky and
how he was homeless and how we had to do
a porn movie because he had no money and
how we turned down all this money to to
make the movie but he turned it down
because he wanted to act in it and
didn't want him to acting and all the
all of these like I can tell somebody
else's story but I think the most
powerful one is when you tell your own
story and I think it depends on who
you're trying to reach but i think that
the personal story has the most impact I
know when I get on stage and I'm telling
a story and it's mine I'm more
emotionally invested into it you know
like I'm more committed to it it's more
personal I can get if i go deep I can
get really emotional about it and it's
it's credible obviously because it's my
story
and I think it's easier for people to
have an emotional connection to me when
I'm telling my story now I don't have
stories about everything right sometimes
my stories may not be fantastic and so
sharing somebody else's story is an easy
way to supplement your own store so
that's why i recommend your own story
for something you're passionate emotion
about and then other people's stories to
supplement next Devon I wrote a book
some years ago I won a couple talk shows
and if you raised your interviews my
question is what are some of the best
ways wrote a book without spending tons
on marketing you don't need to spend a
lot of money on marketing and I think a
lot of the entrepreneurs and authors who
do often end up not getting results not
getting a not getting a return on that
investment that they put in what you do
need to spend some hustle and what a
number one way that I would recommend
the promoter book without spending money
is go connect with all the influencers
in your community who are the people
that this book is for and then connect
with all the people who who can help you
reach that audience so for example the
name of his book I see here's should men
cry and I would be thinking so is this a
lifestyle book you know is this a is
this related to marriage or weddings or
or is it business about crying in
business or not and you know depending
on who you're targeting those are
different audiences right if you wanted
to target entrepreneurs I'm one of the
best people in the world to connect to
to help spread your message if you want
to target you know single moms I'm not
right like i don't i'm not in that space
right you want to sell jewelry I'm not
the guy to talk to right I don't I have
a wedding ring but I don't wear a ton of
jewelry so I'm not the right guy so it's
not just talking people have large
audiences it's connecting with people
who have the audience that you want and
then finding a message that resonates
with them right if you reach out to me
and you're just trying to promote your
book I'm probably not going right back
to you but if you are commenting on my
my Twitter feed comet on my youtube
videos you know I'm going to look at who
is this person what are they all about
and maybe it's an opportunity to an
interview with you or to help share your
story or sure one of the tweets that you
put out right so you want to target
people who have the same turbulence as
you as well as people who are on the
same vibe bright like they believe the
same things as you you have this similar
passion to
create a difference in the industry that
you're in there just attacking it from a
different way and engage with them get
on their radar screen let them know who
you are and then have the ass to do some
kind of promotion interview whatever it
is to their audience to have spread the
word next Orion Dark Knight hey Evan how
can I recognize create opportunities as
an actor and in general this is a big
question but how do you think I can be
successful keep up the awesome work much
love if I was an actor I would do I
would do a combination of things the
first thing I do is try to think how can
I be different what can I be known as
almost even as a gimmick like what what
what could I be known as that's
different in everybody else you know
people were attracted Arnold
Schwarzenegger because he was so huge
right he had these ginormous muscles and
and even though they said you're never
going to get into business with this
long crazy name when you're crazy accent
that was one of the things that made him
stand out from everybody else so I would
try to find something either physical or
in the way I acted or something that I
wore something something is that all
these additions you are one of you know
hundreds of people so I try to have
something that makes me stand out the
second thing I would do is I would be
overly positive and optimistic and bring
energy to everything that you're doing I
can't tell you how many times I might
events and I meet people they come up
and talk to me or I'm speaking and just
they love the positivity I'm always
happy and optimistic and engaging and
talking to you know the receptionist
they're talking to the person who's just
handing out water whatever right like
energy bring it you're on set you know
you're going fought itions you gotta
everybody's like sitting there trying to
memorize lines and they're stressed out
bring energy bring happiness bring
calmness and it just relaxes people and
and again helps you be a little bit more
memorable the third thing I would do is
these are just coming from the top of my
head but but I think it's valuable what
would I do the third thing I would do is
I would go to lots of additions right
like you got to make a name for yourself
you gotta you gotta get out there you
gotta practice and and like hustle right
and partially to to make your name but
also partially
you to get better like you gotta get
better you gotta go and do more and get
better look at my youtube channel right
at doing two videos every day and that
makes me better such as having more
content of it makes me better as a
speaker and you go back on my channel
look at my old videos look at how I am
now I'm much better and that's not
because I'm fantastic or a great speaker
it's because through practice you get
better or anything else you want to
learn French we're going to ride a bike
want to learn whatever it is through
practice you'll get better and every
time you go to an audition the next one
be better in the next one will be better
the next one better and then lastly ah
the forcing fourth thing i would do was
throw a curveball and i would try to
build up my own audience i would try to
build up my own audience I figure out
what I stand for make regular YouTube
videos again the practice being in front
of the camera and and try to make a name
for myself in a certain industry so
again figure out what what it is that
you feel the world needs more of right
what's wrong with the world what's your
solution make out opinion pieces if
you're acting them out or if you're just
being you and being real build up an
audience because that can really help
you if you're entering any contests you
know that audience that you build up can
help vote for you can help get you in
the your audience can help refer you to
potential deals that are coming up and
it also makes you better because you
have more practice so those are four
things i would do good luck man keep me
posted next you know also one last thing
i would if i'm on youtube now right
you're on youtube i put your name right
you're trying to make a name for
yourself put your name put your face
right you have a ryan Dark Knight I
think the thumbnail is like a Batman
figure or something get personal right i
want to say oh that guy right John and
and I recognize your face and I say oh
he's an actor you know it kind of puts
it on my radar puts on everybody's radar
so I'd make things a lot more personal
and last question will you laughs okay
my question is what do you think a man
or women should do if money is an issue
and you need food and shelter but you
also want to follow your passion we're
sure you go local fast food store any
job you can get initially then build
from there embrace the genius of the end
my friend embrace the genius of the end
and that means parallel paths you have
to survive okay and there's some people
who say you need to burn the boats you
got to go all-in you gotta launch your
business I'm not in that camp
I don't believe you have to throw away
all the other options and force yourself
to be an entrepreneur it works for some
people it does work for some people but
I don't think it works for the majority
of people where I think you should do
whatever it takes to survive and I would
ideally take a job where I'm learning
something about the industry I want to
get into so I would just go work at a
fast food place unless your goal was to
build a fast food restaurant then you're
learning something so whatever your goal
is I would try to go learn from somebody
who's done it get an internship get a
get a part-time job get a full-time job
like work your way up learn so you're
getting paid to make mistakes you're
getting paid to get your education and
then you know you're building up savings
and you can start your business on the
side and I think that's the key is you
have business on the side going every
single day half an hour at least every
single day no excuses no breaks you're
tired you came home late you had a rough
day at work half an hour still at least
every single day on your business don't
fall into the trap of being stuck on the
corporate ladder being in a job and then
your business and your dreams slowly die
off okay so parallel paths making income
so that you can support yourself and
learn continue to build momentum through
your business and when it reaches the
point where you can support yourself and
pay your bills then you quit and go full
time when your company and hopefully
start to take off that's it light on the
content in terms of what I'm doing but
heavy on the question so I appreciate
you guys and let me know if you have
questions for next week ideally I want
to try to keep it to like book related
stuff my book your book related process
or what I've talked about this week
which was you know doing things that are
important so thank you guys continue to
believe I'm gonna go see if I can find
my wife and have a quick chat before she
gets to bed so thank you guys I'll see
you soon